here comes sarah palin it was like the
gift of sarah palin in my life
she's just she's my spirit animal i
check her she's your spirit every day i
love her so much have you ever met her
not yet but oh my god can we get sarah
palin on the goddamn line here dude i
think i think we can
arrange that oh my god that was part two
of lisa ann on the sauce cast lisanne
amber sarah palin now amber how old are
you in 2008
i was 14. okay so you weren't legal yet
do you remember the 2008 election you do
remember that do you remember do you
remember
do you remember who was running in the
2008 election uh was it was it romney
and palin no it was uh mccain mccain
john mccain well palin was a star she
was just like i feel like she was our
first celebrity presidential candidate
she was like before obama like i feel
like palin was the one who
was the most trendy or the most like
ridiculous the first one that had like a
personality
the first one beyond
non-politician that that really
hit the pop scene right she was like a
character okay so she was a character
and who who played
sarah palin first and who played it
better
you or tina or tina fey exactly it's
funny because i love tina fey such a
huge tina fey fan and she wrote me into
a couple of speeches and there's some
great quotes out there where tina fey
says uh you know lisa anne played sarah
palin but lisa ans knows more about
foreign policy but i know more about
three ways like she really
she really played this of course she
played her better because they have
script writers and they have all these
people i mean i was given my palin scene
you know all the movies like you're
handed the script the same day and
they're like figure this out and i
but i wouldn't let the production
companies buy my wardrobe because i did
not trust them and i knew i want to be
so specific with sarah's look so i
studied all of her looks and i sew
one of my crafts my secret hobbies can
we pull up uh so what i did was i bought
because you wanted to honor her
perfectly i wanted the suit to look
exactly like hers i but i knew larry
flint loves legs so i knew the suits had
to be short i knew i couldn't trust a
tailor i bought i took in all because
you had to pornify these suits but i
spent more money on my suits than i made
in the sarah palin movies did you really
i did what do you mean how much did you
spend on your outfits and versus how
much you made on those i spent more
money on my outfits than i made because
would you break down the numbers why
how did that work because i knew that
this was going to be big i knew that i'd
wear the suits out on the road feature
dancing and i knew that everybody was
going to see this and i knew that
nothing against hustler but i knew
they'd put me in some weird polyester
like cheap looking and it wouldn't do
sarah justice right this is very
interesting to me as a concept that you
because you didn't feel the actual work
disrespected her
no not at all i mean
no i had a moment nina hartley had asked
me if i would play sarah palin and i was
like i don't know if i'd want to do that
to somebody but then when larry flint's
people reached out i was like for larry
i'd do anything
really the legendary larry rest in peace
just passed away this past year but when
i first moved to california from
becoming pen pals with his assistant who
then became his wife
i became like family friends with them
and would go dinner at their house and
take trips with them so when this came
about yes i did not want to disrespect
her wardrobe because she was so specific
she wore i had the exact glasses she
wore always two pair of lashes not one i
mean i would stand at my tv
and study everything were you thinking
she would see it and you wanted to
no i just knew that the first day on set
we were gonna have our first day where
there was mainstream cruise there like
tmz was gonna be there and all these
even reporters wanted to nail the role i
wanted to name it she nailed it all
right
and i wanted to make it like look i was
in an eminem video as sarah palin like i
just knew that that was an investment
that was gonna make me a ton of money
and that last four years going on the
road and dancing the you know in palin's
suits and everything like that was a
minor investment to market the product
properly to make matters roi on that was
insane right is that what you're saying
insane
insane and there was no way i was
trusting them because they wouldn't have
spent the qual i knew what brand she was
buying i was ordering tari suits like i
was getting the same brands as her
because you know there'd be like look
books where you could look at exactly
where she got and i just tapered them
and tailored them myself
i had my talent agency at that time and
i had my sewing machine in the agency i
had everything pinned and pressed that i
was gonna be doing it just looked like a
sweatshop for hookers like it was like
the weirdest looking place ever and
nailed it lisa can i ask after the
success of naylan palin did you get
approached to play another
political figure or another barack obama
there was a a palin nalin obama
scene that we did
by the way the first one was the one
that everybody knows about we shot six
more because in porno they rang
everything
i did get approached to play tina fey in
a 30 rock parody wow so then i did the
same thing i did the same thing with
tina fey's look and and so i played tina
fey in a 30 rock parody wow i love how
they come up like how do they come up
with the porn names like i'm sure that
instead of 30 rock they called it thirty
[ __ ]
triple x you have this exactly so much
about it like we had to spell sarah
palin's name differently it was p-a-y
for parody protection
and i learned all of that from larry you
know i went with him just playful yep i
learned i went to dc with him to speak
because congress was having an issue
with this this is when parodies were
really becoming a thing
um and he knew everything he was a
brilliant man and look if it wasn't for
larry flynn i wouldn't have this life uh
he why do you owe it to him well because
you know he fought for our rights to be
able to make this a legal tax paying
career to be in the smut business is
what it was called back when he was
fighting that trial if you ever saw the
people like people versus you familiar
with this movie yeah okay so
that's the history of really how this
came about to be legal
and not be considered prostitution or to
abandon certain states you know those
types of things so to me he was our
frontier speaking of sarah palin how do
you think she would have done as a vp
you know
i wanted to go and feature dance in
alaska when i was doing the palin thing
it's the one state that would not let me
go there
because people liked her so much and
liked her politics so much the clubs
didn't want to cause any sort of protest
or what have you so that really made me
start studying her more
she might have come off
unprepared but she's a very intelligent
woman
and she does have that really grounded i
know what americans want because she's a
mom
um she's a real person
she just said some very flippant things
that made it easy to play her when she
said she could see russia from her
backyard i was like
i cannot wait to say that in this movie
like she just did things but she was
unprepared now here's the question
did she earn your vote did you vote for
obama and biden or did you vote for
mccain and palin which you vote for well
i i couldn't i just was too worried that
mccain wasn't going to make it for too
long so it's sad it's sad to admit that
i did not vote for sarah palin at that
time palin i can't believe you asked
you're such an awkward and personal it's
okay
but yeah she said a question that
offends me saying nothing she's talking
about gang bangs and all this and having
fun
don't ask
sorry sailor and i hope that sarah still
wants to interview with us
uh because i would vote for her now she
is at the wrong time if she was during
the trump era everything she said would
have been i agree boom
timing is everything yeah did you ever
hear the dave chappelle com you're a
comedian you've you're an actress uh you
ever heard the dave chappelle thing that
he did about politics and sex
it's a bit where he's like basically
like
um
he's talking with a buddy and he's like
so look i'm with my wife last night the
guy's like hold on excuse me let me just
ask you a question uh who are you voting
for he's like buddy buddy you're asking
me all these personal questions i'm
trying to tell you that i'm having sex
with my wife last night i'm banging my
wife's like i just want to know who you
voted for stop with the personal
questions i'm trying to tell you about
banging my wife it's a bit he talks
about how you know politics is more
personal than sex
it really truly is we were taught to
only talk about it at the dinner table
with family and that's it you were never
allowed to talk about who you voted for
that's the question that stumps or
offense lisa anne did you vote for her
actually you know i wouldn't think i
didn't believe in her but she still
wants to meet her you should no you
should and speaking of voting in polls
yes david we ran a poll sarah palin or
lisa ann
uh
79 percent voted for
lisa am clearly hello
pop it out for lisa
sarah's ig because she's really rocking
right now when she was in new york for
the new york times lawsuit i was like
her style is on point she's super lean
she's very fit i was like
lady you are getting she's just her
instagram handle is naylan palin
by the way during the nail and pale and
era i was banned from all of her social
i was blocked and then she must have
hired a new people blocked from her
social life like i would go on you know
when people block you and then 2008 that
must have been uh facebook super
offended possibly twitter yeah and look
at her isn't she dashing she really
really is she's not lisa ann but she's
like no lisa
she's also dating that young younger guy
the hockey player another thing i love
about who is she dating now she's dating
this hot retired hockey players in his
30s this was a big part of the new york
trip
um how milfy of her people do forget how
milfy she was into the media didn't know
what to do with her
because she was hot and crazy she was
hot and crazy and not the smartest but
also not an idiot and she was the
candidate and she was
attracted didn't know what to do with
her do you know the governor of alaska
is now
no lisa ann no merkelson you're joking i
am not no lisa
lisa she's a sex excellent but lisa
murkowski is a she's in his 30s unless
she's now a governor i thought she was
now a governor anyway the point is she's
running alaska lisa and murkowski
lisa ann murkowski lisa murkowski and
sarah were going back and forth in like
some social media war and i said to
myself self you are going to chances
lisa murkowski's name middle name is ann
go look this up immediately and i went
and looked it up and there it was oh my
god because every lisa from my
generation they're literally lisa
murkowski
[Music]
you